朝、
どうやって起きてますか！
目覚まし時計
お母さん
彼ぴっぴ
彼女...
ちゃん（？）
パパ、じいちゃん、ばあば、ばあちゃん（？）
まぁいろんな起きる要素があるんですけども
まぁなんかもっとこう...
びっくりして起きたら
一番すっきりして起きられるんじゃねぇかということで
僕もちょっとまあ色々試してみたんですけども
今回新しい物を見つけました！
こちら！
なんか...こうゆう類のやつを使ったことがないからよくわかんないんですけど
すっごい怖いんすよ
ええっと　グレネー...ド弾です
ﾀﾝｯ
グレネード弾...でいいのかな？
俺もよくわかんないんだよね
コレ使い方がまずわかんないんだけど
本体＋シェル12個
新品
さばゲーとかでよくある
なんか戦場とかでこう「ドゥルルん」
どぅんぴこー「ドゥルルん」ウワーーーーーーーー
みたいなやつです（ｗ
これを朝投げればすげぇおきるんじゃね？という
うわあどくろマークだ（汗
え、怖いよわかんないよ、え、どうやって使うのかわかんないよ（カッコイイ・・）
とりあえずこれを、こういうの使うらしいです
え、俺怖いよこんなの　使いたくないんですけどぉ
マジほんとに高圧ガスとか使いますからね
誰か起こす(?)前に一回やっぱテストでやっておかないと駄目だね
やります！（ｷﾘｯ
ステップワン、pool`!"#$%!'※+`*{}_?!$'&'("$" (はじめは英語が分かりません）
スマホ：「バン」　はじめ：うわっ
やべぇ、これ。やっべえぞこれ
コツは分かりました、なんか
youtube見てやり方が分かった
（作業中・・・・）
すげぇすげぇすげぇ、なるほど、OK、わかったわかった、俺はマスターした
（作業中・・・）
正直マジでビビってますよ。(汗
こういうのゲームや映画でしか見たこと無いので、
実際にグレネードを殴る、というのは初めてです！
行きます！
へぁ？
うっほほほほほぉーやっば、待って、
耳がキィーンって鳴る。これやべえぞ
この威力ですよヤッバ
ということでターゲットが寝ると思うんですけども、
明日ターゲットも朝早いみたいなので、せっかくなので
ちょびっと(?)音の大きめの目覚ましで、起こしてあげようと思います★
では、おやすみ★
（効果音）ビーッビー
（ターゲット）
ペンペン(?)
ゴミ箱：「バンッ」　ターゲット：「うわあっ」
♪ゴミ箱ゴミ箱ゴミ箱ゴミ箱
♪グーレネードーをー使ってー起きたけーどー
♪結局ー爆発の前にー起きちゃあったーよー
♪グレグレグレグレっ
意味無し！
ゴミ箱：「バン」　ターゲット：うわ！・・・びっくりした！
ハッハッハッハッハッハｗｗ
音がでかすぎてぇ、
ヤバいと思ったから、
ゴミ箱で音を、圧縮しました。
ターゲット：ありがとう・・・　はじめ：ｗｗ
バンッ　うわっ！